welcome to my presentation on mortgage
backed securities
let's get started and this is going to
be part of a whole new series of
presentations because i think what's
happening right now in in the credit
markets is pretty significant from i
guess a personal finance point of view
and just from a historic point of view
and i want to do a whole set of videos
just so people understand i guess how
everything is fits together and uh what
the possible repercussions could be but
we have to start with the basics so what
is a mortgage-backed security you
probably read a lot about these so
historically let's think about what
historically happens when i i went to to
get a loan for a house let's say um 20
years ago and i'm going to simplify some
things and later we can do a more
nuanced but let's say i need
uh well where'd my pen go
let's say i need a hundred thousand
dollars no let me say one million
dollars because that's actually closer
to how much houses cost now
let's say i need one million dollar loan
to buy a house right this is going to be
a mortgage that it's going to be backed
by my house and when i say backed by my
house or secured by my house that means
that
i'm going to borrow a million dollars
from
a bank and if i can't pay back the loan
then the bank gets my house that's all
it means
and oftentimes it'll only be secured by
the house which means that i could just
give them back the keys they get the
house and i have no other responsibility
but of course my credit gets messed up
but i need a million dollar loans the
traditional way i got a million dollar
loan is you know i
would go and talk to the bank
this is the bank
and they have the money
and then they would give me
one million dollars and i would pay them
some type of interest probably let's
just say i'll make up a number i mean
the the interest rates obviously change
and we'll do few future presentations on
what causes the interest rates to change
but let's say i would pay them 10
percent interest and for the sake of
simplicity i'm going to assume that
the loans in this presentation are
interest only loans in a traditional
mortgage you actually your payment has
some part interest and some part
principle principle is actually when
you're paying down the loan
the math is a little bit more difficult
with that so what we're going to do in
this case is assume that i only pay the
interest portion and at the end of the
loan i pay the whole loan amount so
let's say that this is a 10-year loan
let's say it's a 10-year loan
so for
each year of the 10 years i'm gonna pay
a hundred thousand dollars in interest
100 000 per year
right and then in year 10
year 10 i'm gonna pay the hundred
thousand and i'm also going to pay back
the one million dollars right so if we
think about it from you know let me just
a year
one two three da da
nine ten so in year one i pay a hundred
thousand year two i pay a hundred
thousand year three i pay a hundred
thousand dollars
a year nine i pay a hundred thousand and
then year ten i pay the hundred thousand
plus i pay back the million dollars so i
pay back
1.1 million so that's
kind of how the the cash is going to be
transferred between me and the bank and
this is how
i don't want to say traditional loan
because this isn't a traditional an
interest-only loan but
for the sake of this uh presentation i
want to how it's different than a
mortgage-backed security the important
thing to realize is that bank
would have kept the loan these payments
i would have been making would have been
directly to the bank and that's what the
business that historically banks were in
um you know another person you
and you have a you have a a hat
you would let's say you're extremely
wealthy and you would put a million
dollars into the bank right that's just
your life savings or you inherited it
from your uncle and the bank would pay
you i don't know five percent
the bank would pay you five percent
and then take that million dollars give
it to me and get ten percent on on what
i just borrowed and then the bank makes
a difference right it's paying you five
percent and then it's getting 10 from me
and we can go later into you know how
they can pull this off like what happens
when you have to draw the money et
cetera et cetera but the important thing
to realize is that the these these
payments i make are to the bank that's
how loans worked before the
mortgage-backed security industry really
got developed
now let's do the example with a mortgage
back security
now there's still me i still exist
and i still need a million dollars
instead of going to the bank or actually
let me let's say i still go to the bank
let's say i go to the bank the bank is
still there
the bank is still there
and like before
the bank gives me
a million dollars
and then i give the bank 10 percent per
year
right so it looks very similar to our
old model but in the old model the bank
would keep
would keep these payments itself and
that million dollars that it had is now
used to pay for my house
then there was a an innovation instead
of having to get more deposits in order
to keep giving out loans the bank said
well why don't i sell these loans to a
third party and let them do something
with it and i know that that might be a
little confusing how do you sell a loan
well let's say there's me and let's say
there's a thousand of me right there's a
bunch of sals in the world right and we
each are borrowing money from the bank
so let's so there's a thousand of me
right i'm just saying any kind of large
number doesn't have to be a thousand
right and collectively we have borrowed
a thousand times a million so we've
collectively borrowed one billion
dollars from the bank
and we are collectively paying 10 on
that right because each of us are going
to pay 10 per year so we're each going
to pay 10 percent on that billion
dollars right so 10 of that billion
dollars is a hundred million dollars in
interest so this ten percent
equals a hundred million
now the bank says okay i just all the
dollar one billion dollars that i had in
my vaults or whatever and you know i
guess now there's no physical money but
in my databases is now out in people's
pockets um i want to get more money so
what the bank does is it takes all these
loans together that billion dollars in
loans
and says hey investment bank so that's
another bank
why don't you give me
a billion dollars
so the investment bank gives them a
billion dollars and then instead of me
and the other thousands of me paying
the money to
to this bank if we're now paying it to
this new third this new party right
i'm making my picture very confusing so
what just happened
when this bank sold the loans they
grouped all the loans together and it
sold it in a big kind of it did it on a
wholesale basis it sold a thousand loans
to this bank so this bank paid a billion
dollars for the right to get the
interest and principal payment on those
loans so all that happened is this guy
got the cash and then
this bank will now get the set of
payments so you might wonder why did
this bank do it well
i did i kind of glazed over the details
but he probably got a lot of fees for
doing this or maybe he just likes giving
loans to his customers whatever but
the actual right answer is that he got
fees for doing this and he's actually
probably going to transfer a little bit
less value to this guy
now
hopefully you understand the notion of
actually transferring the loan this guy
pays money and now the payments are
essentially going to be funneled to him
i only have two minutes left in this
presentation so in the next presentation
i'm going to focus on
what this guy can now do with the loan
to turn it into a mortgage-backed
security and this guy's an investment
bank instead of a commercial bank and
that's important well that detail is not
that important in understanding what
mortgage-backed security is but that
will have to wait until the next
presentation see you soon